So, how are things floating around
easily? How does a Snapchat give me hair
and sunglasses when it's on a live
video? It's all just CGI. You really
start to see that when you watch, when
you pay attention to things. Look at
this bag. This is a bag of food. For
one, I don't know why he's not like
pushing it out of his face because
>> been rehydrated already. So, we added
water to it and the shrimp soaked back
up the water and it's actually pretty
tasty.
>> [music]
>> It's coming so close to his eye. Like,
why didn't he just push it out of the
way?
But, watch the corner.
Do you Do you see that?
All right.
Here's a corner.
>> [music]
>> You see the corner. Now, that corner
goes literally into his flesh and
disappears. [music]
It doesn't bounce off of his head. It's
going through his flesh
because this is CGI.
And you can even see his eyebrow. Watch
his eyebrow just disappear.
Check this out.
>> [music]
>> Look, his eye You see his eyebrow? Look,
skin
eyebrow coming back.
Sorry, it's all loading. I don't know
why I said that. But, look at that.
Skin, eyebrow. [music]
You might say that's, you know, bad
pixelation or something. But, you can't
deny that this food is coming so close
to his face. Why didn't he just swat it
out of his way? But, it's literally
going through his
forehead.
There's no denying that.
So, you see this red dot on the bag,
right? And I don't know why it would
disappear at some point.
But, it does.
I don't understand that because if it's
[music] a 3D model, I'd understand why
the dot would disappear. But, one side
has a white label.
>> We're flying up here in space and those
are
>> has a red dot. But, the red dot's not
there.
The red dot's not there.
And it's back right here.
Where is it? Where's the red dot?
We do have to eat our vegetables even in
space. But, don't worry, they do give us
mac and cheese. Interesting [music]
stuff here, guys.